[Music]
the issue of abortion pills in America
returns to the courts today a federal
appeals court holds a hearing to
reconsider a judge's ruling that the
abortion drug mifipristone was wrongly
approved by the FDA meanwhile with
abortion now banned in some states more
Americans are seeking abortion pills
from Europe CBS news's Hayley Ott spoke
to a doctor in the Netherlands who was
providing them
Amsterdam's historic squares and narrow
canals are just part of the morning
commute for Dr Rebecca gumperts I don't
live very far away her organization ate
access helps Americans get abortions
even though they're thousands of miles
apart in other countries it's not
controversial and abortion is recognized
as a human right
experts say Aid access is a significant
provider of abortion pills for people in
states with restrictive abortion laws
meaning many who seek out medication
abortions in those States will be
getting their prescriptions from a
doctor in this European city
here's how it works someone seeking an
abortion in the U.S fills out an online
form which depending on what state
they're in is reviewed by a health care
professional at home or in the
Netherlands they get a prescription for
abortion pills that can be filled
domestically or at an aid access
recommended Pharmacy in India and the
pills are mailed to them
Dr Gumpert says demand has skyrocketed
since Roe v Wade was overturned last
year so we have seen an enormous
increase in requests
and especially of course from the States
where there's restrictions and I think
at this moment we're seeing between
a thousand and 1500 requests per day
the FDA says that medication abortion
which in the U.S involves taking the
drugs mifipristone and misoprostol is
safe and it's approved in over 80 other
countries
but eight access is working in a legal
gray area Professor Greer Donnelly from
the University of Pittsburgh specializes
in abortion law if the state's or
federal government don't have
jurisdiction to really go after those
people
um then just because it's illegal
doesn't mean it's actually going to stop
so even though somebody outside the U.S
might be breaking the law by prescribing
abortion pills there's no way the law
can reach them exactly you know Donnelly
says an FDA personal use exemption May
apply to Americans ordering abortion
pills from overseas in 2019 the FDA sent
Aid access a warning letter but Gumpert
sued in response and the regulatory
agency took no enforcement action the
FDA did not respond to our request for
comment as far as Dr gumperts is
concerned she's just doing her job I'm
acting in accordance with my medical
professional oath that I am supposed to
make sure that people that need medical
care that they will get it that's what I
do and that is my my laws and my
conscience that I abide to Aid access
has a growing network of American
clinicians shielded by new state laws
that are able to prescribe abortion
pills at home
but while the future of miffapristone
hangs in the balance of the courts
Gumpert says her European operation
won't be going anywhere for CBS
morning's Hayley yacht Amsterdam
[Music]